[Music]
have you ever wondered what Disney
Villains looks like when they were
younger there's some of the funniest and
most mysterious characters out there but
they're often also much older than
anyone else well not anymore
wait until you see what Maleficent would
look like as a teenager
don't forget to subscribe to our Channel
and give this video a big thumbs up
today we're discussing 10 Disney
villains reimagined as teenagers Cruella
De Vil
Cruella Deville is one of the most
iconic Disney characters ever she is so
popular that she was one of the few
Disney villains that managed to appear
in other cartoons her name is so popular
we often use it without even realizing
it's related to 101 Dalmatians
Cruella is a nickname we usually give to
someone who's not exactly a nice person
and it all started with this 1996 Disney
movie but while she might be one of the
most famous Disney villains out there
she got the short end of the stick when
it comes to her looks we never find out
how old Cruella is but she could be the
same age as Anita as they were
schoolmates but what we do know is that
she's definitely older than teenagers so
what would she look like if she suddenly
became a teenager this version of a
young Cruella is illustrated by Kristen
Reeves who did a fantastic job at
showing us what Cruella would look like
as a teenager her hair looks just a bit
more stylish although she's still
rocking that half-black half-white do
but what's entirely different is her
face doesn't this version of Cruella
look much better the character from 101
Dalmatians is played by Glenn Close who
also had a very interesting look when
she was a teenager but we bet Glenn was
never as mean as the character she
portrayed on 101 Dalmatians his month if
Cruella De Vil is Disney's most popular
villain Emma has to be one of
funniest if you don't know who is Liz
you should find a way to watch The
Emperor's New Groove right now ESMA is
considered a villain because she got
fired by her boss and now she wants
revenge it seems like that would be some
pretty solid villain motive right well
yzma is also one of the funniest
villains you'll ever see
and she easily steals every moment on
screen ESMA is very slim and elderly
looking although we're not quite sure
how old she actually is she has a pale
lavender skin wrinkled face and very
long black eyelashes although she's a
villain
ESMA is a hilarious character with many
one-liners and scenes that made us
giggle uncontrollably of course every
Disney villain has their dark side and
vengeance is hers so what would she look
like as a teenager do you think his mom
was always being spirited or did she
once have a softer side Jack Overland
frost 315 from deviantART brilliantly
illustrated what yzma would look like as
a teenager
although we can definitely see traces of
all disma in her teenage self
she does look kinder ESMA was played by
Eartha Kitt and her portrayal of this
Disney villain can't be topped
speaking of yzma did you know that
Patrick Warburton was never in a studio
together with Eartha despite them
sharing so many scenes
Queen of Hearts Queen of Hearts is often
mistaken for the Red Queen from through
the looking-glass but the two are not
the same characters the Queen of Hearts
is one of the very few obese Disney
villains as she's on a mission to rule
the Wonderland she's not exactly the
nicest character ever and her features
don't do her any favors
she has a very unique dress with many
colors black hair and a gold crown on
her head this look was designed on a
website called azalea's doll and it
shows what Queen of Hearts would look
like as a teenager this version of the
Queen seems much kinder and it looks
like she replaced the crowd with a tiara
she has long dark hair but her dress is
still pretty much the same she does have
a kinder look than the original
character and it makes us wonder what
made Queen
hearts become so neat in the first place
Verna Felton voices the 1951 Queen of
Hearts version but her character was
replaced by the Red Queen in the 2010
movie adaptation of Alice and wonderland
this version is played by the one and
only Helena Bonham Carter who has a very
interesting teenage look herself Captain
Hook get ready because you'll be totally
blown away by Captain Hook's youthful
look but first let us remind you of what
Captain Hook actually looks like there
are two villains on our lists that are
afraid of getting old and this pirate is
one of them Captain Hook is the main
villain of everyone's favorite Peter Pan
tale he's also one of the most ruthless
villains out there Captain Hook is
slender with fair skin he has long black
hair a thin mustache and a hook on his
left hand Peter Pan is the reason why he
lost his hook so naturally he's not very
fond of the boy we never learned how old
he is
but he definitely has an aged look have
you ever wondered what he looked like if
he was a teenager well so of weeks and
we found the answer
Kristen Reeves brilliantly reimagined
Captain Hook as a teenager and we're
very fond of this look check it out do
you see the resemblance he no longer has
the long dark hair or a mustache but we
still see some resemblance in the 1991
movie hook
Captain Hook is played by Dustin Hoffman
whose younger look does look similar to
the reimagined version of the Peter Pan
villain speaking of Peter Pan did you
know that the word bangarang is actually
Jamaican slang it means uproar
disturbance or disorder we can
definitely see why the elderly Captain
Hook disliked the Lost Boys purse Allah
along with Cruella Deville Ursula is
also everyone's favorite Disney Villains
did you know that Ursula is not actually
an octopus perhaps she's this angry at
the world because she's only a squid
with six tentacles animators had a very
hard job creating Ursula with eight
tentacles so they decided to settle for
six Ursula is pretty Ovie's she has a
lavender skin a mole on her right cheek
far too much makeup she wants to rule
the sea world but have you ever wondered
what she looked like when she was a teen
this illustration shows a very
impressive representation of teenager
Scylla while the original villain has
white hair this Ursula has long black
hair and she doesn't even have tentacles
she's a mermaid which in our opinion is
a much better choice Ursula was always
supposed to have tentacles but she'd
definitely have an interesting backstory
if her teenage self would actually be a
mermaid did you know that
Ursula's original look was actually
inspired by a drag queen called divine
from the pink flamingos movie which is
definitely not made for children
although divine passed away we bet she
would love the fact she got portrayed as
one of the most iconic Disney villains
ever dr. Vasily a dr. phacelia is the
main villain in The Princess and the
Frog
along with his shadow sidekick we've
shown you Princess Tiana reimagined as a
couple of things including a minion but
we've never shown you any other
characters from The Princess and the
Frog dr. Vasily a has a dream he wants
to become the most powerful man in New
Orleans and he'll do anything in his
power to make that happen
his looks don't really do it many favors
although we have to admit he's probably
the most fashionable villain out there a
tumblr user maybe Tim reimagined what
dr. Vasily a would look like as a teen
this version of the villain is quite a
fashionista while he's still rocking the
same clothes it looks like they've been
upgraded to something that could easily
be seen on a runway and is that
high-heeled we see his feminine look is
absolutely wonderful and this version
would put a very interesting spin on the
original The Princess and the Frog story
do you think he'd still be as
power-hungry and mean what is shado
still have a different personality we
have so many questions and we'd love to
have the answers Mother Gothel speaking
of favorite villains although she
kidnapped a girl and kept her in a tower
for 18 years Mother Gothel is quite an
exceptional character along with Captain
Hook
she's the other Disney villain with a
fear of losing her youth she's
incredibly manipulative and narcissistic
but she can easily charm whoever she
wants just to get her way we never
learned her real age but centuries have
passed since she found the magical
flower so it's safe to say Mother Gothel
might be over 100 years old just like
most Disney Villains she's slender and
has pale skin her red lips are
accompanied by the long curly dark hair
and she is quite a fashionista when it
comes to her gowns a tumblr artist
called Andals reimagine what she would
look like as a teen although mother
Gotham's main wish was to stay young we
never really learned what she wanted to
keep her youth and we never saw her as a
child this version of Mother Gothel is
amazing and it certainly fits her look
speaking of Mother Gothel while it might
look like she dies from her fall she
actually dies of old age as she falls
she turns into dust and all that's left
is her cloak we hope she learned her
lesson that you can't escape getting old
no matter how hard you try Jafar we've
shown you plenty of reimagined versions
of Princess Jasmine
and even Aladdin but we've never given
you a different look of Jafar one of the
meanest characters in the movie Jafar is
defined as a wicked Vizier a part-time
magician and an amateur seer his mission
is to rule the universe overthrow the
Sultan and take revenge on Aladdin his
looks most definitely fit his
personality he looks mighty tall it has
a unique goatee a turban a large robe
and a staff shaped like a golden snake
have you noticed that all Disney
villains apart from Ursula and the Queen
of Hearts look slim and they're all
somewhat elderly while Jafar never
reveals his age it's safe to assume he's
way beyond his teenage years a
deviantART artist called young 86 took
this opportunity and created a younger
and much more stylish version of the
Disney villain check him out we're not
sure how old he's supposed to look but
he looks like he might as well have his
own Jafar fashion line it's certainly an
upgrade from the Jafar we know
the animators behind Aladdin said they
created all characters based on simple
shapes for example Aladdin is composed
of two interlocking triangles formed by
his chest and his pants jasmine is
pear-shaped and Jafar has a teenth shape
they kept those shapes in mind
throughout the entire movie which is why
Jafar looks so slender lady tremaine
here's yet another slender Disney
villain Lady Tremaine is Cinderella's
arch-nemesis and she gets the award for
being one of the worst Disney
stepmothers ever her mission is to make
Cinderella's life as miserable as
possible all while climbing the social
ladder to secure better wealth for her
family Lady Tremaine might not have such
distinctive features as some of the
other Disney villains she's slim with a
pointy chin and a heart-shaped hairstyle
we're not sure how old she is
but this version of Lady Tremaine shows
us what she would look like as a
teenager she still looks just as
fabulous you have to admit that Lady
Tremaine does know how to look stunning
in her gowns the teenage version of the
character has a dark red dress and long
black hair her makeup and her dark look
still show signs of the vengeful side of
Lady Tremaine which one do you prefer
the old lady tremaine or this new
younger version speaking of Cinderella
Lady Tremaine really missed out on not
being nicer to her stepdaughter did you
know that Cinderella was the very first
Disney Princess that married into a
royal family instead of inheriting the
throne blues and glass slippers at a
party really does pay off doesn't it
Maleficent last but not least let's talk
about Disney's most vengeful fairy ever
she's the strongest and most powerful of
all creatures but instead of using her
powers for good she wants to take out
Princess Aurora Maleficent was such a
compelling character that her portrayal
went beyond Sleeping Beauty in 2014
Disney released Maleficent the movie
starring Angelina Jolie is the
villain we're not sure how old
Maleficent is we can tell you that she's
not a teenager so why not reimagine what
she'd look like in her teenage years
this might just be our favorite
illustration from the ones we've shown
you today this is a young and a very
modern version of Maleficent and we can
totally see her fitting into today's
world despite still having horns on her
head she's totally rocking that selfie
look we love how the artist kept
Maleficent signature purple and black
colors we bet she is the most popular
kid in school did you know that Eleanor
Audley the actress who voiced Maleficent
in Sleeping Beauty also voiced the
previously mentioned lady tremaine she
actually acted out her scenes in costume
which helped her get into character but
also inspire the final looks of the
Magnificent Maleficent and that's it for
10 Disney villains reimagined as
teenagers we hope you liked it for more
Disney videos check out 15 Disney
Princesses reimagined as anime
characters see you next time
[Music]
you
[Music]